on va maintenant parler de golf et puis
particulièrement de la nationale golf
wiki de retour à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines cette semaine
de jeudi à samedi les passionnés de golf
vont pouvoir se retrouver autour de leur
passion et d'un salon au golf national
pour nous en parler nous avons avec nous
Antoine Robin vous êtes le
co-organisateur de cet événement est-ce
que tout est prêt à quelques jours de
l'événement oui on est quasiment prêt on
est en train de finaliser les derniers
préparatifs et on sera prêt à accueillir
notre public dès jeudi matin à 10h et il
y aura notamment un immense salon
installé sur le Golf National est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus oui
absolument c'est le point majeur de
cette nationale golf Wick c'est un grand
salon où on va retrouver une centaine
d'exposants aussi bien les fabricants de
matériel
club butter balles équipement pour le
golf et aussi tout ce qui est autour du
tourisme tout ce qui intéresse
globalement les golfeurs dans leur
pratique générale du golf
et évidemment tout au long des trois
jours beaucoup d'animation des lois
gagnées de quoi se restaurer bref de
quoi passer un vraiment bon moment pour
les passionnés et en particulier essayer
le matériel puisqu'on a la chance d'être
sur un vrai golf avec un practice de
très très bonne qualité au golf national
ce qui permet d'essayer les clubs de
faire des fittings donc du des clubs sur
mesure avec les plus grandes marques du
marché est-ce qu'on peut dire que le
Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est l'endroit
idéal pour organiser ce type d'événement
clairement c'est pour ça que on l'a
choisi et que la Fédération nous a
gentiment accueilli c'est le temple du
golf en France on se souvient que la
Ryder Cup était là les championnats du
monde amateur l'année dernière l'Open de
France tous les ans donc ça permet
d'avoir aussi deux parcours un parcours
de très grande qualité l'Albatros qui
permet d'accueillir des compétitions
avec des pros et puis le parcours de
like qui est très bon aussi qui
accueille des compétitions pour les
amateurs et pour les jeunes le samedi
matin et puis
se passe très largement suffisant pour
qu'on ait donc une grande tente
d'exposition et puis le petit Green et
le practice pour tester de façon réelle
les clubs oui vous l'avez dit vous êtes
soutenu par la Fédération Française de
Golfe oui en fait l'idée est venu en
commun avec la Fédération on leur
proposait de monter une compétition un
peu innovante sur le parcours de
l'Albatros qui est le parcours référence
et la réponse du président Pascal Griso
a été extrêmement rapide il nous a dit
ça nous intéresse à condition que vous
fassiez venir le salon du golf chez nous
et là on organisera la grande fête du
golf français donc évidemment on n'a pas
hésité une seule seconde pour nous
c'était la meilleure combinaison
possible j'imagine que ce sera aussi
l'occasion de rencontrer des sportifs de
haut niveau évidemment on a une
compétition qui s'appelle l'alliance du
de la nationale golfwick l'alliance
c'est une formule de jeu ou un joueur
pro joue avec un amateur donc une
expérience assez exceptionnelle pour les
amateurs et donc à le titre on a plus
d'une vingtaine de joueurs
professionnels qui jouent sur différents
circuits ou qui ont joué sur les grands
circuits l'européennes tours ou le
Seigneur tour et puis des pardon des
plus jeunes également et donc ça permet
d'approcher très près dans des
conditions idéales des joueurs de très
haut niveau la plus grosse star
peut-être sur cet événement H20 je vais
faire des jaloux si je dis qu'il y a une
plus grosse star mais on va dire que un
joueur emblématique comme Grégory avress
sera là un Grégory un vrai qui a été
notamment deuxième de l'US Open il y a
quelques années et puis on a des jeunes
de très bons niveaux comme David rabetto
enfin voilà je peux pas tous les citer
parce que on en a plus d'une vingtaine
mais c'est du très très bon niveau il y
aura énormément beaucoup de visiteurs
est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un
événement qui monte en puissance alors
oui évidemment il monte en puissance on
a eu une naissance un peu particulière
puisque on devait organiser pendant le
covid et bien entendu les conditions
nous ont pas permis de le faire donc la
première année a été purement digitale
la deuxième année en 2022 on a eu des
conditions météo un peu particulières la
neige j'y étais il faisait -2 réels
moins 8 ressenti donc c'était des
conditions un peu spéciales très
difficile voilà et là ça va être parfait
puisque les conditions seront bonnes et
que au bout de 3 ans on va dire que
c'est l'éclosion de cet événement et ça
s'adresse vraiment à tout le monde cet
événement même si on n'est pas forcément
fan de golf oui oui ça s'adresse à des
pratiquants
réguliers classiques ou même pas
régulier qui voudraient découvrir en
fait c'est ça l'intéresse c'est qu'on
peut avoir tout un tas d'occasions
d'acheter du matériel de façon
intéressante de le tester d'être
conseiller par des spécialistes et puis
de découvrir toutes les facettes de ce
sport qui est magique c'est c'est des
conditions
très abordables et très très agréable
pour le faire
est-ce qu'il y aura d'autres éditions
que vous avez prévues évidemment on
compte bien revenir tous les ans à peu
près cette période c'est pour nous une
date idéale puisque c'est le lancement
de la saison en général en golf c'est là
que souvent les marques de de club
dévoilent toute leur nouveauté c'est
aussi une semaine assez calme sur les
sur les circuits professionnels ce qui
nous permet d'avoir de très bons joueurs
donc voilà nous pour nous c'est vraiment
le schéma idéal d'organiser cet
événement pendant trois jours fin mars
début avril tous les ans on l'espère et
bien merci Antoine Robin d'être venu sur
le plateau pour nous en parler je vous
souhaite aussi bon courage pour
l'organisation de l'événement on le
rappelle la nationale golf 8 qui est
programmée ce jeudi 30 mars et jusqu'au
samedi 1er avril